they started in silence
the message from Liverpool labor is a
patriotic party
[Music]
for
the first time singing the National
Anthem largely in unison
[Music]
[Applause]
will only be victorious if he can be
trusted with the economy
and today he committed to keep the cut
to the basic rate of income tax but
reverse scrapping the top rate I do not
think that the choice
um to have tax cuts for those that are
earning hundreds of thousands of pounds
is the right choice when our economy is
struggling the way it is that not
everyone agrees on reducing the basic
rate of income tax I don't think it's
the most targeted way of using the
resources that we've got at this moment
in time yet as the conservatives move to
the right on tax
some argue labor must now lean more left
yeah in France they've just uh fully
nationalized EDF and that's with a
fairly Centrist modest government under
Emmanuel macron in Germany they've
nationalized a major gas supplier in
Spain they've put extra taxes on the
super rich in the Netherlands which got
sent to right government they've hiked
the minimum wage by 10 which is much
higher than their current rate of
inflation so you're seeing much more
radical policy around Europe in response
to radical times and I think Labor's got
to step up now
the leader's allies disagree a lot of
people here say kirstan's not being
radical enough what's your response oh
well we've got a massively radical um
set of policies to put forward to the
country this uh this week with the clean
green future that Kirsten Mr James
you'll create half a million jobs it'll
give us energy security and it means
we're leading the fight against the
climate emergency I think that's pretty
radical to call that not radical simply
demonstrates they don't really
understand how the economy works
in recent years this conference has been
full of drama and division battles
between left and right this time though
that has largely dissipated If we're
honest it is so far A little bit dull
but this sudden sense of unity is partly
because for labor power now seems to be
within reach
they may be on the way up but it could
be a long journey ahead Joe Pike Sky
News Liverpool